my pillow CEO and founder Michael indell  or just pillow you all that stuff I just  said you can replace with just pillow  um is now questioning whether Ron  DeSantis really won his election now why  do they care about this well they care  about it because a lot of the people  Trump did endorse lost DeSantis got a  very soft barely an endorsement for  Trump and dramatically over performed  and the reason they care is DeSantis is  leading Trump in many 2024 polls so  what's the answer well when all you have  is a hammer everything looks like a nail  that hammer is it was rigged and now Ron  DeSantis is being accused of not having  really won by Mike pillow the Santa's  one there's no doubt this shows you what  they're afraid of though